[Music]
we have gone over the decision from the
supreme court
from yesterday which said you can't
shield
your tax returns from manhattan
prosecutors anymore
donald trump that's the decision made by
the supreme court the documents
with reportedly almost no delay will be
turned over to manhattan district
attorney cyrus vance
and will be made part of the grand jury
that cyrus vance is running okay
donald trump exploded
at news of this putting out a statement
on the quote
continuing political persecution
of president donald trump this is a very
funny letter in which donald trump
alternates between referring to himself
in the first person and the third person
it's riddled with lots of other wacky
things and
i want to go through it with you because
it is actually incredible
that this is a letter from a former
president of the united states it's
almost like a a third grader wrote a
joke letter
let's get right into it quote this
investigation is a continuation of the
greatest political witch hunt
which hunt capitalized we'd never know
why in the history of our
country whether it was the never-ending
32 million dollar
molar hoax which remember recovered far
more than the 32 million that it cost
trump goes on to say which already
investigated everything that could
possibly be investigated russia russia
russia
where there was a finding of no
collusion that's of course untrue
or two ridiculous crazy nancy inspired
impeachment attempts where i was found
not guilty it never ends
so now for more than two years new york
city has been looking at almost every
transaction i've ever done
including seeking tax returns which were
done by among the biggest and most
prestigious law and accounting firms in
the united states
now remember when you have someone do
your taxes
you are always signing off and saying
you
are warranting that the information you
give to them is true
they are merely completing the taxes
based on what you tell them so
the idea that the prestige of the
accounting firm
when i go and i tell our accountant uh
here's how much we made
here's how much we spent the accountant
has me sign something where i
where i am saying it is my
responsibility if this information is
untrue if i'm lying
about the value of a building or
whatever that's on me that's not on the
accountant the prestige of the
accounting firm seems irrelevant
okay continuing uh the tea party was
treated far better by the irs than
donald
trump the supreme court never should
have let this fishing expedition happen
but they did
now what's funny is trump puts fishing
expedition in quotes
that suggests it's trump who's skeptical
that it was actually a fishing
expedition
trump doesn't seem to understand what
quotes mean
going on to say this is something which
has never happened to a president before
it is all democrat inspired in a totally
democrat location new york city and
state completely controlled and
dominated
by a heavily reported enemy of mine
governor andrew cuomo now if trump has
any evidence that cuomo
is involved in any of this he should
release it there is no evidence i've
seen so far
trump continues these are attacks by
democrats willing to do anything to stop
the almost 75 million people the most
votes by far ever gotten by a sitting
president
who voted for me in the election an
election which many people and experts
feel that i won
i agree so trump still can't get away
from the it was stolen stuff
that incited the riot in the first place
the new phenomenon of head hunting
prosecutors and ag's who try to take
down
their political opponents using the law
as a weapon
is a threat to the very foundation of
our liberty that's what is done in third
world countries
even worse for those who run for
prosecutorial or attorney general
offices in far-left states and
jurisdictions
pledging to take out a political
opponent that's fascism not justice
funny that trump talks about third world
countries and fascism
trump's presidency and his
authoritarianism was more reminiscent of
that
than anything we're seeing right now
trump goes on to say and that is exactly
what they are trying to do with respect
to me
except that the people of our country
won't stand for it in the meantime
murders and violent crime are up in new
york city by record numbers
and nothing is done about it yeah mostly
under trump's presidency
our elected officials don't care all
they focus on is the persecution
of president donald j trump i will fight
on just as i have for the last five
years even before i was successfully
elected
despite all of the election crimes that
were committed against me
we will win and it's unclear what
exactly
trump believes he is going to win to me
this is the rantings of a highly
triggered but in particular very scared
individual remember there are political
consequences
to some degree of a presidential
candidate not releasing their tax
returns trump knew that
and he still decided releasing them
is worse for me than keeping them
private
keeping them secret and being criticized
for it
that means trump knows the content of
the tax returns is not good for him
and that's why he's acting in this way
what do you think is in the tax returns
i've explained my thoughts many times
before uh
and at this point do you think it even
matters we'll have more coverage of this
on our instagram page david pakman show
and if you want to see the level
of anti-vaxx emails that we are now
getting
check my personal instagram david.pacman
where i posted a really extreme
anti-vaxx email that i received this
morning quick break
much more coming up a lot of the shirts
you see me wearing on youtube are
actually made by a company called
teddy stratford i love these shirts and
that's why i asked them to be a sponsor
of the show
it really is the most innovative shirt
you can buy
because most slim fit button up shirts
give you this weird stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are you
don't get that with the teddy stratford
shirts because
all of their shirts come with a patented
zipper
hidden beneath the buttons which
prevents the chest from stretching apart
like that but most importantly
just overall it makes the shirt fit much
better and look better the carefully
designed shirt is
also cut in a way that improves the look
of your upper body physique it has a
really nice elegant
close fit that other shirts don't really
give you it also has a specially
designed collar
that won't fall down and lay flat which
i love
the difference all around with these
shirts really is noticeable
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout